your ground
again
it's what officials in Virginia are
calling a once in a generation happening
when a police officer is attacked
abducted and taken hostage in his own
squad car all this leading up to a
deadly officer-involved shooting
all right guys go
please
get back
I often say that these body worn camera
videos speak for themselves I believe
this is one of those instances
um You probably picked up that that our
officer was
um attacked
to say the least the the perpetrator
attempted
viciously and violently to disarm our
uniform Fairfax County police officer
and I think you saw that rather clearly
on top of that he was literally abducted
and taken hostage in his own marked
police car it happened on May 11th in
Fairfax County Virginia when a license
plate reader tracked a stolen U-Haul a
Fairfax County Police Department Officer
responded to a gas station where the
vehicle was parked
body camera video shows the responding
officer approached the suspect later
identified as 38-year-old Brandon
lamigne
driving U-Haul yeah if you talk to me
real quick over here
what did I do la Magna can be heard
asking the officer what he did as the
officer explains he's being detained
entertained it's reports stolen
just seconds after the officer
approaches the magnet a fight breaks out
the officer calls out via His Radio
saying La magnet is reaching for his gun
sir you're a good get off my gun
our holsters that
um and I have one on right now that that
carry our
firearm have a double retention feature
I'm not going to describe that double
retention feature because I don't want
that to be public knowledge
but thankfully we we've had this double
retention double retention feature
holster for several years because one of
the two retention mechanisms was Was
Defeated it was the second retention
mechanism that ultimately contributed to
this officer living to fight another day
because I firmly believe that the
perpetrator the assailant in this case
if he were to have
lodged that gun free from the officer's
holster would have killed him would have
executed them there's no doubt in my
mind the struggle continues as the
officer again asks lamagnay to get off
his weapon
Nerf get off my gun
signal words
sir you're not going down around right
get off my gun
oh
foreign
magnet opens the officer's squad car and
both partially enter the vehicle
look get off my gun get off my gun
as the struggle continues the vehicle is
put into gear and begins moving
get off my gun
the vehicle is thrown in reverse and
crashes into a nearby McDonald's hitting
two other vehicles along the way
meanwhile other officers respond to the
chaotic scene just crash it to the
Walmart
Richmond Highway it's a gas station
right next to a McDonald's fast food
restaurant there's cars there's people
uh there there certainly could have been
there weren't and thankfully there
weren't there could have been
pedestrians either coming or going into
the McDonald's they they were inside
thankfully their cars were parked and
unoccupied outside so certainly that
runs through our minds and it runs
through the minds of the officers in
real time when they're dealing with a
potentially real deadly threat and and
that that assault that went mobile that
kidnapping that abduction that went
mobile uh happened in in real time in a
small amount of space so our officers
are are trained like police officers
across the country to consider their
background to consider the presence of
others who Could Be In Harm's Way But
oftentimes in spite of those best
efforts there is some inevitable
potential that other people could be
harmed and I put that squarely on the
perpetrator he chose to do this and he
responded to his actions uh his actions
in my opinion his intent rather was to
kill that police officer so but
certainly that's a consideration and
anytime you have a critical incident
there will be training uh conversations
that that result
um there there are certainly some parts
of of this critical incident that we
will continue to examine and will be
part of our training curriculum going
forward either to enhance or to alter
but but that's all part of our review
officials say two of the responding
officers opened fire after the squad car
crashed in the car in the car what car
TV
[Applause]
I also hear the engine revving and you
can hear the engine revving because our
perpetrator is stepping on that gas
pedal he's not done
so any notion that when that vehicle
came to rest in the McDonald's parking
lot it was over it wasn't over it was
still very much a very active scene so
the investigation will will examine the
the actions of the police officers
ultimately
um we'll share all of our findings and
and in real time with the Commonwealth's
attorney's office but a lot of those
questions will be subject to the
investigation responding officers then
escort the wounded officer from the
squad working to treat his injuries
[Music]
everybody expedite
McDonald's
the Fairfax County Police Chief says the
responding officers acted to save the
life of the Wounded officer but my
assessment uh in in this particular case
was this was a this is a once in a
generation happening to a police
department even a big Police Department
like Fairfax big and busy this doesn't
happen but once a generation for a
police officer to be the subject of
someone attacking him trying to pull his
own gun out of his holster so and it was
very much in progress he was assaulted
he was taken hostage he was abducted
the actions of the two responding
officers I believe were more than
appropriate given what we know
then and now the investigation still has
to move forward we still have to ask
questions that we need answers to
um and and some of those are forensic
questions with forensic answers so the
investigation is not complete the
investigation is ongoing but these
officers and I think uh you know believe
what you're seeing there these officers
ran toward gunfire and their only intent
was to save the life of that police
officer who was screaming for help La
magnet was pronounced dead on the scene
the uh perpetrator was struck several
times uh I don't know if we know right
now we may as the investigation moves
forward which or which round or rounds
proved to be the Fatal rounds
um and and from which firearm they came
from obviously to uniform Fairfax County
police officers or Firearms so we may be
a point at a point in the future to know
that it happened so quickly you see the
second officer in the word I used at the
scene
um was
um
was a bravery or hero I think I used the
word hero I mean you see that second
officer who who is running literally you
know you hear the the phrase routinely
about First Responders cops firefighters
running towards gunfire he was running
towards gunfire literally and you can
see how he did that so when he exposed
himself and he didn't know and and I
imagine as our investigation will
continue to to reveal you know to the
extent that either officer or both
officer even knew that our own police
officer was still in the car that's all
part of our investigation did they think
it was just the perpetrator did they
think the officer was still in the car
that's that's
something we're going to ask is the
investigation moves forward but
um but certainly this was a a violent
crime in progress and and the officers
who responded did so quickly thank God
that they were
uh so close and they were able to
respond so quickly and thankfully you
might pick up on this our officer had
his microphone attached to his upper
vest as opposed to when I came on you
had to pull your microphone out of your
holster and put your thumb on it so I
think the fact that his microphone was
so readily available on his on his out
of s carry he was able to to transmit
that that someone was taking his gun and
I think he said
it leads to the perpetrator six times
get off my gun get off my gun get off my
gun and I believe he made at least three
radio Transmissions to the effect that
he has my gun he has my gun he has my
gun and by he has my gun clearly
um and again
facts not opinion the the perpetrator
has both hands and one hand on that gun
most of the most of the time and
thankfully the the retention feature
prevented that that gun from coming out
of the holster and and the officer who's
about a three-year veteran stayed on his
feet so I think that's consistent with
his training he made a radio
transmission in real time under a great
amount of stress and other officers were
able to get there and and save his life
from here both a criminal and
administrative investigation are
underway into the officer-involved
shooting reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie